el día global de acción por la justicia
climática una jornada que manifestantes
de todo el mundo aprovecharon para que
sus exigencias sean escuchadas el foco
de las masivas marchas fue glasgow sede
de la cob 26 hecha múltiple crisis es
una crisis múltiple pero tiene las
mismas raíces es una economía quebrada
una economía a mañana y nos está
poniendo a todos al borde de la
catástrofe podemos arreglar el planeta y
podemos abordar la desigualdad y la
pobreza globales miles de personas
también apoyaron la causa desde londres
y la explanada de la alcaldía de parís
espero que las cosas cambien haber
venido aquí me hace ver que no soy la
única en preocuparme por el futuro lo
que me da más esperanza
en seguro cientos de personas se pasaron
entre manos y esta enorme pelota
inflable representación de un planeta en
llamas bucles de hueso
se está celebrando la convención de las
naciones unidas sobre el cambio
climático en glasgow han tenido
reuniones cada año durante 26 años la
crisis climática aún no se ha resuelto
dado que esto no se puede detener los
ciudadanos de todo el mundo estamos
saliendo a actuar por nuestras vidas
seguridad y futuro
en estambul los ambientalistas exigieron
proteger el planeta para las
generaciones futuras
y en australia las manifestaciones
regresaron a sídney y melbourne
rechazando la postura del gobierno que
no se unió a las promesas hechas en la
cumbre climática para reducir las
emisiones de metano en un 30% la primera
semana de la cob 26 logró también
acuerdos para la eliminación progresiva
del uso del carbón y acabar con la
deforestación para 2030 sin embargo
activistas de todo el mundo no han
escondido su escepticismo ante las
promesas que denuncian podrían ser de
nuevo una feria del bla bla bla